[Musique]
le réseau de transport en commun car
jeunes fête ses 20 ans au service des
réunionnais car jaune aujourd'hui
réalise plus de 5 millions de voyages et
parcours 7 millions de kilomètres chaque
année depuis sa création en 1996 le
département de la réunion n'a cessé
d'améliorer la qualité du service rendu
quand je n'a cessé d'évoluer en vingt
ans
le départ comme la présente n'ont cessé
de vouloir apporter améliorée
les transports de voyageurs en
termes de performances en termes de
confort avec maintenant le car jaune
qu'on utilise tous les moyens
de technologies modernes de
communication le wifi vous pouvez
construire votre déplacement à
votre iphone vous pouvez choisir même
votre mode de déplacement donc le car
jaune est à la pointe de
de ce qu'on peut faire de mieux au
niveau de transparence lors de la
conférence de presse organisée pour
l'occasion les anciens conseillers
généraux délégués aux transports au sein
de la collectivité étaient présents pour
partager leurs anecdotes
j'ai assisté à la terreur du grunge
étaient considérables des états combien
transport et donc je vote fruits taux
était le vice président chargé des
transports et donc on mettait en place
ce réseau en mature et donc on avait un
bureau d'études que je ne faisais des
propositions et est arrivé le moment de
leur couleur est donc le gorille qu'ils
nous disent on vous propose trois
couleurs possibles 1 le jeune 2e jaune 3
le jaune donc le président twittos et ou
même on y écoute et vous donnez nous un
choix sont revenus quinze jours plus
tard avec deux propositions de couleur
effectivement c'est le jeune qui
paraissait le mieux sur une note beau
soleil et c'est comme ça allait et
venait la couleur jaune du cas car je ne
souhaitais faire de ses 20 ans au moment
de célébration et de partage une
campagne de télévision et d'affichage se
déroulera du 28 septembre au 4 octobre
un grand jeu ticket d'or sera lancée
dans les bus et les gares enfin une
journée festive est programmé dimanche 2
octobre jardin l'état le dimanche 2
octobre au jardin de l'état de 10 heures
à 17 heures vous avez une journée
festive qui est gratuite et ouverte à
tous où vous pourrez rencontrer les
différents
ferrante personnes les différents
métiers du réseau car jaune à travers le
village des métiers vous aurez également
un atelier bois de bois de goyavier une
exposition historique sur les
différentes étapes des 20 ans du réseau
comment le réseau s'est construit une
exposition de véhicules avec un quart
courants d'air et la présence du car à
étages et beaucoup d'animations
comme comme des jeux lontan et un grand
concert de basse-terre et frédéric jours
rendez vous donc ce dimanche 2 octobre
au jardin de l'état pour souffler les 20
bougies de cars jaunes qui fait partie
intégrante du patrimoine local et de
l'identité réunionnaise
[Musique]